foreign
ER is in Philadelphia hi Alexander
welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you thank you for taking my
call I appreciate your time sure what's
up
um so I want to buy a garage ornament
and I want to be on the smart side of
the spectrum and have a conversation
with you before I end up on the stupid
side of the stuff
okay how expensive a car
[Music]
everything it's about a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars cool what do you
make
uh take home uh with me and my wife it's
about uh 14 000 a month with net
so 150 Grand
I don't I don't whatever that is
probably close to 200 yeah okay
all right um as far as debt is concerned
Why don't you ask the question that's
okay
that's good that's okay how much debt
uh 150 000. on what
uh my house okay
and
um what's your uh nest egg
how much money you got I got about 800
000 in retirement I got about 430 000
you know in liquid assets I guess I have
two sons and I have about ninety
thousand dollars in each of their 529
plans okay so the rule of thumb I use on
uh toys
which you're at the level of toy on this
um yeah and I've got some toys so the
rule of thumb I use and that I teach I'm
a guy it's in my DNA I don't have a car
payment I I have a Subaru like I had
enough you're gonna pay cash for this
car right I'm gonna do what you tell me
I mean you say okay if you're if you're
not gonna pay cash for it don't do it
number number one rule okay number two
rule is cars go down in value things
with motors and things with wheels cars
boats sea Doos they're sisters
um I've got a bunch of things that go
wooden wooden and I like stuff like that
but they all lose value
and so we don't want to have a general
rule of thumb is you're a millionaire
okay A little over a million dollar net
worth
um if I understood the numbers correctly
and um and it sounds like you make a
couple hundred a year
the trick is we use a rule of thumb that
says don't don't buy things with cars
with motors and wheels all total
including your other car your Subaru
other stuff like that that equal more
than half your annual income because
they go down and we want to have small
amounts of things going down in our life
now you've got an unusually high net
worth you're paying cash for this you're
probably going to violate that 50
percent
when you buy it
okay matter of fact we know you are
because you make about 200 a year and
you're going to spend 130 just on this
one car and your other cars on top of
that are going to put you over that
um
normally I would say that's a no-go it
kind of makes me question it here
um
a little bit
what's your question well I mean I I
just don't want to put too much in
things that go down in value and I'm
trying to look at the ratios of your net
worth it's like uh not to you know it is
a g it is a Nissan GTR I don't know if
you know anything about Nissan GTRs but
they're very very very hard to find and
if you go on auto a Trader or something
like that right now
um they're they're astronomically priced
even in the used Market likelihood if
you're the new rapper the new one the
new Raptor just came out 700 horsepower
um they're running about 120. okay but
they're not going to go up in value
I understand even though they're like
they're much like your Nissan that
you're talking about that yeah I've
looked at that car it's a very sweet car
um and so yeah you can you can do it but
what you've got to realize is you've put
a a little bit more into a depreciating
asset because 10 years from now let's
face it that thing's not going up in
value
no no I mean I've got a 60 a 1960
Corvette that's frame up restoration
that is fabulous and I've had it for
probably 10 years I don't think it's
gone up a diamond value I don't think
it's gone down any but it might it might
have gone up a little bit
but uh the classic cars some of them
like that some of them will go up a
little or a super super rare item you
know that you can't get like stuff
that's running off the auto auction that
kind of stuff the rare car auctions
sometimes those will go up in value and
but I don't think your Nissan's going to
qualify and I don't think that raptor is
going to qualify for that so anyway all
that to say the way I'm not going to
tell you what to do the way I make
decisions is am I putting too much of my
asset base and things that are going
down rather than up and normally our
guideline is a pay cash B don't have
total of more than 50 percent of your
household income in there now an
exception of that would be let's say
let's say you called in you had eight
million dollars in mutual funds and your
household income was a hundred thousand
well we wouldn't hold to that 50 of the
hundred thousand right I see what you're
saying because you could afford to buy
the thing for 130 if you had eight
million dollars and drive it off a cliff
tomorrow and you wouldn't even notice
financially
right that's the point so you're right
on that you don't have eight million but
you got a million and a half probably we
didn't talk about your house Equity but
um you know you're right on that and
you're doing great so you're you're not
going to go bankrupt because of this but
I wouldn't go buy another one Alex no no
this is this is this is it for me I mean
I don't I don't I haven't I don't drive
a fancy car
um you're about to not really like that
but I just uh I've always liked this car
for the last you know however many years
it's a sweet it's a sweet vehicle I just
don't want to you know I think I I you
know I respect everything that you say
you obviously are in the Mana position
uh for a reason so I just didn't want to
you know well you get the principles I'm
using yeah I understand I completely
understand what you're saying and so I
based on those principles you're on the
bubble
you wouldn't be on the dumb side
um you know if your net worth was 500
000 I'd say don't do it
okay yeah my house is worth a pretty
good amount of money too and I don't owe
that much on the house like I said only
a 150 on the half what's it worth
uh I would I just had my real estate
agent looked at he said a million six a
million seven okay so your net Worth's
three million
yeah yeah
okay I feel like that moves the needle
that does move the needle that moves it
in your favor see you see what I'm
talking about here that's the whole
thing right I just don't we can
rationalize our butts off and I
appreciate you calling I appreciate the
spirit you're being humble about it
you're not being smart Alec you're not
being sarcastic you really don't want to
know that house threw it over the edge
in my book you're okay then yeah I'm
good I'm sleeping good tonight Alexander
if you buy this this car and I'm happy
for you and she's the one that just
yelled at all of America so just keep in
mind that that's you that hundred and
thirty thousand dollar car you got he's
got over two million dollars in net
worth three three yeah definitely get it
and get me one too I'm just kidding
there you go that is a sweet vehicle
y'all look it up if you haven't looked
it up oh man all right that's so that's
the thing and these numbers do change
you know here's an example okay
everybody says okay what percentage of
my income should I spend on food well if
we give you a percentage
that's true for people that make a
hundred thousand what if somebody made a
million that's right you don't need to
spend that much on food
because they'd be large
and in charge okay okay I mean so
percent you know these things skew out
if you have a very low income you're you
know very poor okay you're just barely
getting started you have to spend a
larger percentage of your income on food
that's right so you know to just meet
Necessities so these things skew out the
principles that we give you skew out
based on net worth based on income being
at extremes and a three million dollar
net worth is an extreme in America today
God's very successful way to go
Alexander yeah I'm happy for him you
know the thing is you just got to get
these principles down quit buying 50 000
cars when you make fifty thousand
dollars and you got no money right
that's just straight up stupid that's
the point of these principles and he's
not even anywhere he's not even in that
on the in that same book much less the
same chapter or the same page well
that's the point you know Dave we yell
at people a lot for doing dumb stuff but
we're equally happy for the people who
have worked hard they've got the money
then yes spend your money money is fun
to spend it's fun to give save and spend
just fun to enjoy it's fun to enjoy and
I think people think that we have
forgotten that but we have not forgotten
that it is fun to spend